so I'm not going to hold out on the
punchline the punchline of my talk is
this is a total misnomer as far as you I
can tell no one has really got irregular
time series whipped yet so you can leave
now if you're hoping for a magical
solution I don't especially like talks
that promise you something and don't
deliver I have done that so I won't take
it personally if you head out now
but I do think it's an issue that needs
to be talked about more and I'm sort of
personally hoping if I talk about it
people will think it's important and
someone who actually you know knows a
fair amount of statistics will do more
than I can with this subject okay so
here's our outline first thing why you
already care and if you don't care why
you really should care where aren't a
regular time series in human behavior to
start with I actually work at a startup
called one drop we are a diabetes
management platform we are trying to
integrate all data about anything that
could possibly be related to someone's
diabetes and start making smart
decisions for them and giving them smart
recommendations so I can tell you that
we look at tons of irregular time series
anything that involves human reporting
is going to be irregular it depends on
people's mood it depends if they were
carrying their phone for people with
diabetes they actually sometimes wear
implants that monitor their blood
glucose levels and you think great I
actually have some regularly sampled
data every five minutes well no not
really because they take the devices off
they get uncomfortable and they need to
be recalibrated they run out of
batteries so even when you think you've
got a human who's you know got a
tracking device on just like a wild
animal no it's never going to happen
so that's health reporting those of you
who work in financial markets the
example I'm fairly familiar with
especially is FX these are irregular
right I mean we plot them and we talk
about this data coming through in
microseconds across the Atlantic New
York London and back but actually it's
irregular right it doesn't come out
evenly spaced intervals it depends when
people are buying and selling and even
computers are not doing that on a
regular schedule if they're smart and
then another one parliamentary election
cycles now in the US actually
we do have a regular time series for our
elections but you Europeans are more
fond of occasionally holding these
sudden elections and so you make
yourself a new problem as far as
updating your political data so anywhere
you have an underlying continuous
ongoing truths but irregular
measurements of that truth you've got an
irregular time series right anything
where I'm just not measuring on a grid
it's really hard by the way to get any
human responses and let alone
temporarily regular responses so those
of you don't work with data that you
have to sort of drag out of your human
subjects which I totally get not
criticizing them here's a great example
so some of you might have heard about
this in 2015 this major paper and the
science that was studying how discussion
impacts people's attitudes about gay
marriage turned out to be totally fake
and the way we found out it was totally
fake we the community not me in
particular where that researchers were
trying to continue like wow this is
awesome like they got these amazing
response rates like how can we do this
they start sampling and they get like
10% of the response rate and people
started asking what's going on so that's
an example of especially anything
related to people you're always gonna
have a hard time but you are also always
going to have time even if you're a
natural scientist so if you went into
the Natural Sciences because you don't
like your regularity because you think
people are kind of annoying and hard to
study which is true you still have
problems right so I know we've got a
bunch of astronomers here they can tell
you far better than I that they have got
problems too with missing data when
they're trying to take regular time
series there's technical failures right
anyone who's worked with hardware knows
once in a while something blows up it
got overheated it just got old it wasn't
happy if you're looking at ground-based
telescopes you've got weather issues it
was just cloudy there was a hurricane
you've also got things that are just
sort of intrinsic like from where we are
to see this interesting galaxy I have
three other galaxies in between right
that's just not going to go away this is
also relevant to the climate study and
paleo climate proxy data in particular
you're trying to
rocks or ice that have isotopes you can
use to date this is how we figure out
how much carbon there was in the
atmosphere at a particular time these
are hard to find so the example I'm
showing here I'll talk a bit about later
it's trying to look at the Asian monsoon
season and how it has changed over the
last you know couple of millennia it's
not that easy to find the rocks you want
in random caves and you know various
countries so you take what you can get
and similarly biology experiments here
especially more in laboratory
experiments we still know those of us
who have been graduate students we don't
actually want to be in the lab 24 hours
a day taking a regular series so I know
when I was a graduate student sometimes
I wonder if I was even studying my own
behavior a bit and not just the system
because intrinsically it's like well
when did I measure it right so in a lot
of biology experiments if there is
something a human had to do it's not
gonna be on a regular schedule so 4x
honest and endogenous reasons the
Natural Sciences will always face
irregularities of measurement just like
the human sciences you will have more
data but you will have the same problem
so this is all me saying statisticians
get on it and we need some better
methods and here's why
so why should you worry in the mean time
why can't you just sort of hope for the
best
or ignore the problem well one reason
I've already shown you this problem is
everywhere and the more sensors we have
the more data we're collecting the more
big data we're doing the more things
will get irregular right because we have
a finer granularity of measurement maybe
a regularity we didn't see before
now emerges right for example the census
in the US we do it every 10 years I want
to think of it as regular but it isn't
really right maybe it was moved up a few
months maybe it was moved back a few
months so even when you think you've got
periodic data i'm question that so what
should you do well you might start with
Wikipedia right oh this is an area I
haven't dealt with let me go find those
five packages that everyone uses and run
through those if you do this with
unevenly spaced time series this is what
you will find on wiki to put this in
perspective look at the Simpsons one I
wasn't sure was entirely appropriate so
I left
Kim Kardashian actually has an even
better wiki page than the Simpsons
so they both strictly dominate time
series or a regular time series time
series has a very nice wiki page so the
existing solutions there are actually
more I do feel if anyone wants to work
on the wiki page it could use some
updating but here are the Scarman
strategies from what I have seen one is
you can look at each non gapped bit of
the series so this might work especially
say for those astro people who most of
the time they are taking regular
measurements and then the cloud comes or
you know the exoplanet drifts away they
have to wait a while and then they get
another regular series if you've got
enough data great and there's very easy
ways to do this especially with pandas
and numpy you can sort of break up those
chunks and turn them into separate data
points you can also do feature analysis
rather than temporal analysis right
sometimes even though you have a time
series it's not appropriate to think of
that way right let's say you're actually
studying something that is cyclical and
you're not really expecting to see
temporal behavior so an interesting
example of this yesterday for those who
went to the mobile activity talk we
talked a bit about how actually you
wouldn't want to think of it as a time
series right I'm just walking I really
want to study the process of walking not
so much like the time of walking more
common you can resample and then sort of
carry on and close your eyes and hope
the problem will go away people do this
I don't mean to talk about this in a
disparaging way at all it actually works
pretty well pretty often so resampling
just means you say I'm gonna sort of
drop some of my data and make it into a
regular time series so that the
assumptions I need to be true are true
somewhat artificially what's sad about
that is that I lose data right I'm
literally I just struggled to get my
data especially for things where it's
really hard to come by enough and I'm
gonna throw some of it away so that's a
little bit sad some people are very sad
about losing their data so they impute
their data what do they do they say I
don't want to lose data so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna sort of add data
I'm gonna do some sort of linear or
Gaussian interpolation and sort of
imagine what that missing data will look
like this too I don't mean to disparage
it it is done very often most of the
times very
successfully and it's sort of the best
we've got for the moment in many cases
but I'm kind of interested in doing
something sensible without impugning or
losing data can we use everything we
have but not add things so that's what
I'm going to be talking about before I
do though I do want to just highlight
some pitfalls of imputing data every
method has pitfalls this is no different
one of them is sometimes when you try to
patch right are there with interpolation
or maybe you just stick your chunks
together and ignore the fact that you're
missing some you can have frequency
shifts so especially if you're looking
to find out if there's some sort of
periodic elements your data you want to
be aware of this you might be able to
say yes there is some periodic behavior
but what you won't want to do is quote
that actual magnitude because chances
are you're not correct and you're
incorrect in a biased way right it will
always shift up it won't sort of be
spread in a random way similarly when
you randomly timestamp random time
sampling right which is when you take
those sub sequences you basically add
white noise again not the end of the
world but especially if you have a very
low signal-to-noise ratio you want to
think twice about this right because for
example in the talk we just saw
sometimes you have error and result same
order of magnitude right if you already
have that problem and then you're gonna
add more white noise you're really going
to be left without any signal at all
so again very context dependent pitfalls
in general even for the methods I'll be
showing you soon error varies with
skewness of the distribution of the gaps
so when you look at your time series you
don't just think about what you know you
have to think about how the data was
missing right was it truly random random
how right there's different ways to be
random was it a gamma distribution was
it a normal distribution what was it
exactly look at the skewness of those
gaps so here in a really a landmark
paper from 2011 I think the first paper
the heads seriously looked at the errors
in these processes in a long time from
geophysicists because this problem
bothers them a lot we see that the
skewness of the distribution
of the times that are missing really
impacts how these methods do and really
differentiates them so if we look at
this top graph we can see that the
Gaussian kernel that's the yellow has
the lowest error with the highest
skewness it seems fairly robust these
other methods sort of crumble but it
depends on your distribution right so
this is the same measurement I think it
was the auto the autocorrelation
function your estimation we can see now
that the blue is also not so bad at a
highest kunis that's a linear
interpolation so what kind of underlying
time series you have if you even know
will also impact what method you should
choose and how much trust you should
place in that method and in some
circumstances a particular method can be
really disastrous so here you are seeing
those giant red error bars that's the
loam Scargill method which I'm actually
going to be talking about today but you
do need to beware in some cases
especially cases that violate the
underlying assumptions you can go very
wrong so you need to know your data
before you start your analysis we all
know this but the truth is we all sort
of cut corners if we got a sensible
result we don't worry so much about
backtracking and did it make sense
that's fine most of the time I don't
know if I want my doctor or my airline
pilot making a decision that way but
maybe for more exploratory data analysis
that's okay what do you need to worry
about skewness in the distribution of
your missing time right is it some sort
of normally distributed nice symmetric
function or not how much of it is
missing also is very important so some
methods are quite robust even to a lot
of missing data others are very very
good but as soon as you get over some
threshold maybe 15% of the data missing
it's not going to do so well and it sort
of collapses all of a sudden very
disastrously so this is an area where
you want to run your own tests on sort
of I don't want to say fake but simulate
a time series that you think you're
dealing with before you decide you also
want to know what kind of noise you have
the kind of noise you have will impact
how these methods do as well for those
of you who are not familiar with
different colors of noise we're looking
at a power spectral density you might
think of these as Fourier transforms
often we assume we're working with white
noise which means your noise sort of
comes in at all frequencies I used to
work at a physics lab I never saw white
noise in my entire life everything was
one over F which is pink noise in other
areas like human audiology you're
looking at red noise so something to be
aware of as well okay so now we have
gotten past all the bad news and I want
to look at some periodic data right I've
got an irregular time series but I have
pretty good reason to believe it's
periodic so here's an example of this
anyone know what this is it's also
labeled it's an RR Lyrae it is a very
regular star it's sort of blinks on and
off it has the same brightness wherever
it is in the universe so astronomers use
this to gauge distance so for them when
they're trying to identify these things
they're really looking for this pattern
but you can see even they have missing
data like we talked about right they was
cloudy the satellite blocked my
telescope whatever it is I want to find
a way to nonetheless extract the
periodic data now this example is pretty
fake right I mean I can probably just
eyeball this or even marking out with a
pencil and I know what the answer is I
don't really need anything fancy for
this what about this though so here
we're looking on the on the right hand
side that's a graph of a particular gene
expression during development of a
biological organism now here we've got a
couple of problems and I'm going to ask
you to sort of try to unsee that dotted
line this is not my data or I would have
really liked to remove that dotted line
that sort of makes it obvious but try to
imagine that you've just sort of got
this chunk and you've got this chunk and
you've gotten this and you have an idea
that you would really like this to be
periodic because you have this idea as
do other biologists that you can explain
segmentation and repeated units in
biological organisms depending on their
developmental gene expression so you
really want this to be periodic
hopefully it's not just an emotional lot
hopefully you have an intellectual basis
so then you you apply your lumps gargola
periodic Ram and you do in fact find
some periodicity right and you are
actually able to extract this value so I
think this is a really great example of
where this can be helpful where you have
to work with
irregular time series and you can
actually extract very useful information
so here we see the lungs garble scar
glow periodic gram and we see there's a
clear peak right we clearly see periodic
behavior even though it doesn't even
seem like we measured a full period
so unlike Fourier transforms where you
often use a minimum amount of data and
you also need it to be evenly spaced
here we are able to draw conclusions
even without that so this is a fairly
cool method it came out in the 1980s
mostly from astronomy but is now used in
many fields here are the details I won't
go through these in too much detail but
you'll see that this looks very much
like a linear linear fit to science
series and that's because it is right so
it's just like a linear regression
except here we are using those science
series it looks also just like the
discrete Fourier transform right that is
actually just a special case the
difference is that the loam Scargill
periodic gram is much more flexible I
don't need to have orthogonal basis
functions I don't need to have evenly
spaced data and I don't need to have
exactly two to the endpoints right there
are some really annoying things about
Fourier transform when you're working
them with them in a lab that you can
escape here so again this might all
sound quite familiar because it is key
difference like I said the basis
functions are much more flexible they
merely need to be independent at the
times measured not even independent
overall time they don't need to be
orthogonal which means you can sort of
pick even an irregular series of your
sine waves that you want to project on
to your data can be unevenly sample
that's the whole reason I'm talking
about it and there is no data imputation
this is really important because it
means we are not losing data but we're
also not adding data that we have sort
of made up in a way we're not adding any
of our own biases there's also a handy
p-value so if you want a way to sort of
compare different fits or a different
time series you have more of an
objective way to do it whereas Fourier
transform is sort of looking at it
deciding how you feel about the noise
and again you can have any number of
points rather than two to the end points
so here's another example of this
seeking cycles in sunspots so we have
sunspot observations since the sixteen
hundreds as you can imagine we sort of
look at them better now
I assume we've got a couple of computers
keeping an eye on them versus the 1600s
Ivan gave us a couple of guys in Italy
and that was probably it or other
countries I don't know for sure but the
idea is it was sort of a regularly
sampled right I imagine during the
plague or during whatever words you hot
guys had going on over here the the
quality of the sampling was not so high
right so nonetheless we are able to
extract a period from this and you can
also see the difference between the loam
Scargill fit and the discrete Fourier
transform so the discrete Fourier
transform is I would say somewhat
misleading it's much wider than it
should be it also has this second peak
that isn't really significant but if I
don't have some sort of objective way to
decide I could be wandering sort of what
is that oh my goodness can you guys see
that yes
apologies I can sort of see that smaller
peak and I might wonder if there is
something to it right and if I don't
have a way to deal with my irregular
irregularly spaced time series but I'm
actually looking at here is a peak that
I probably got in some way because I had
a drop data or add data to accommodate
the needs of the Fourier transform
versus little M Scargill uses exactly
what I have and therefore it gives me a
more reliable narrow peak by the way it
is supposed to be at eleven years and
that's exactly what I got okay so this
is really wonderful right I don't have
to make up data I don't have to sort of
ignore assumptions of the model to
safely use it and Python already does it
and not only does it do it but it does
it in many different packages so if you
already use sy PI and you don't really
want to deal with anything new great
you've got it inside pi you've also got
it in astro ml and finally you've got it
in GATS PI I would recommend this one in
particular because it has a much faster
implementation so here you can see the
the order of the scaling as your sample
size grows and you can see one curve
particularly stands out and that's the
that's be Loomis Cargill fast what that
does is use the intuition which is
actually just two mathematical facts
that you probably have which is when I
compute a couple of signs and the
projections those are not unrelated to
the others right especially because I'm
not requiring orthogonal functions there
should be some relationship and so when
I use the fast implementation I do need
to use a grid of regularly spaced
frequencies which is not my data
it's the functions I'm using to project
onto and if I do that I can get an order
and log and scaling which is really nice
for people who are dealing with a ton of
data um you can also roll your own I
think sometimes there is not enough
emphasis placed on this this is a great
way to understand how the algorithm
works and to also see that some of these
algorithms are really not complicated
right it's a couple of for loops so this
info also is accurate as of June 2015 so
if the N log n really matters to you and
you love Astro ml or Sipe I could be
wrong since then okay
finally the great holy grail okay well
for finance people the holy grail is the
future right you don't actually care
what causes the pricing I think for the
rest of us who study anything else we
care less about predicting the future
and more about causality right I really
want to know what caused why as the
authors of this paper I'm going to talk
about stated learning temporal causal
structures between time series is one of
the key tools for analyzing time series
data right why do I care what happened
in the past mostly because it explains
how things work irregularity and
sampling violates basic assumptions
behind many models for structure
learning right so I would say all of the
great triumphs of modern statistics have
in time series have to do with regularly
spaced data right we don't really have
this Holy Grail yet for irregularly
spaced data so we're trying to find a
sensible way to implement Granger
causality for a regular time how many
folks have heard of Granger causality
okay so not not if not just a few it's a
fairly commonly used metric basically
what Granger causality does is it
doesn't get too philosophical it's
that if this thing if I use X plus
everything else I know about the
universe and that is not the same as not
using X then X has some causal
relationship that's the claim it's a
fairly weak claim very simple to state
and understand what's a good way to see
this right like you can actually sort of
try to go through this and come up with
different ways of determining when
they're not equal what many people do is
as a shorthand is to use Glasgow
regression who is familiar with lasso
regression probably just about everyone
yeah so for those who don't know lhasa
regression is a way of running a linear
regression that also penalizes
coefficients it does it in a way that
tends to make coefficients disappear
rather than get very small even though
we're penalizing size so this can be
very useful basically for feature
selection which in a way is what Granger
causality is like also check out if you
don't know then stats models this test
has already been implemented I don't
know if everyone else has noticed this
but I noticed when I look at Python
conference talks for like five years ago
versus now usually five years ago it's
someone talking about how they just
implemented this right now everything is
like I'm using these awesome tools and
they're all ready and they're easy to
use so this is another great example of
that okay so what did the authors add in
this paper bahador ian liu they thought
well how can we look at Granger
causality and move it to a regular time
series and they made two important
points first areas with more regular
data when we predict those we should
care about them more because that is
getting us back to those models we
understand so if I have something like
this green region with regularly spaced
data and preferably more regularly
spaced data I'm gonna weigh that more
than this red region by the way it's
that top time series I'm trying to
predict from the bottom I'm gonna weigh
that red region not so much right
because I have this sort of one straight
point I'm going to try to predict it but
when I'm predicting that and thinking
about the behavior of the whole time
series I'm gonna worry less about that
region the other point they make oh the
other point they make is cluster data
like this red region on the bottom that
not so helpful right lots of points are
good if they're spaced apart from each
other
lots of clustered points right
predicting this red point versus this
red point it's kind of redundant right I
mean unless they're wildly different
which will mostly think making you think
I've got an instrument problem but
unless they're wildly different they're
not going to tell me much more so in
that way I actually want to take this
green region again even with just one
point that individual point is going to
be weighted more than each of these
individual points so thinking that they
rewrite their own version of lasso
regression there's a couple of things
that are different from lasso regression
right so we've got those weighting
function in the front if you wanted me
to and you'll also see this weird symbol
this is their weird symbol for thinking
how are we gonna deal with the irregular
time series right because I don't have a
grid so how do I handle that vector
multiplication and here's what they do
so the one weighting factor comes from
this first intuition right that
regularly spaced data should count more
my second weighting factor comes from
the other intuition that clustered data
is redundant and not helpful and then
finally to figure out how to do this
distance relation what they do is they
go with a Gaussian kernel you can
actually try out a bunch of things see
what works for you but I do just love
that Gauss made it onto currency way
back in the day this is how you would
implement this please don't take photos
because there's actually a couple of
errors in the code I left the working
code on my computer in New York and how
to retype it so I promise to post the
working code but mostly you see here
that there's like a couple of for loops
it's actually not that complicated right
I mean sometimes we're all sort of
reticent to dive into a paper do I want
to learn a new method when I've already
got this awesome sci-fi and stats models
and pandas like do I need new stuff
unfortunately you do need new stuff for
a regular time series because it's very
much a work in progress but you can do
really cool things so we see that here
what they did is actually apply their
model to a graphical causal Granger
model and they were actually able to
figure out which areas were causally
related
in the Grainger sense not any stronger
sense of the word to each other and
these are sort of different missing data
sub selections they used to see what
that performance looks like okay so
that's actually a rap just to remind you
I did warn you but this talk was miss
named irregular time series are far far
far from whipped I would really like to
see more work in this area we really
need future work we're gonna have future
need for that work and in the meantime
please do be careful with your data
these are my sources so if you want the
sources they will be in the slides and I
just want to thank PI data hi great talk
I'm a recovering astrophysicist so I'm
far too familiar with the launch goggle
one thing I would extend from what you
were saying so one of the problems we
traditionally had was it never accounted
for errors a classic lumps goggle it has
been generalized and has been Bayesian
generalized if you really want to go the
full hog that you actually have some
idea what region you're going into but
the only other extra thing that I kind
of want to add to what you were saying
was that again with the Long's goggle
you're missing data can become important
in the you will actually if you've got
periodic missing data cycles you'll see
that in your lungs goggle obviously but
it also alias with other signals so you
still have to be careful with these
things but it is definitely useful when
you don't have regular space stuff
any more questions
your talk said all the lots of good
stuff about lumps Kegel someone
mentioned that there was error
management that wasn't necessarily as
ideas is there anything else we should
be worried about is it a lot more
expensive computationally and even for
year for instance is it a lot more
expensive well as the things that we
should worry about before trying to
implement it on not so regular data so
to me as someone more computer science
oriented what I'm most concerned about
is that order n-squared implementation
as far as expenses is that what you
meant like huh yeah so there is this
order n log and implementation now that
works very well I would stick with that
as far as I know but I would be curious
as to your perspective I don't believe
that introduces new kinds of errors to
worry about just the usual provides us
and you do have to use those regularly
spaced basis functions you can't use
anything okay if they are no more
questions please Frank are you Colleen
Nelson